[Musica]
ma che cazzo di musica hanno messo bene
a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo video
sono vari j
ci siamo sud gender capp ho sputato
mentre dicevo questa cosa e io 20
ragazzi non ho idea di non chiedetevi
che cosa sia perché non lo so what
io vorrei giocare in teoria si può
perfetto è una roba sacco e questo è un
bene credo sia un panno anche questa in
teoria dovrebbe essere anche questo e
questa è una budget dei ragazzi è una
roba molto strana io andrei sul primo
pene questo qua ho visto una chiave che
si allunga e più tondo più ha senso
questo cazzo di gioco che se c'è un
televisore a che cazzo ne ho voluto
vederla stasera è non voglio sapere che
com'è andata a finire bene ragazzi è
uscito e non voglio sapere che cosa ha
fatto non è perché l'ha fatto e ci si
può alzare da questa sedia non la voglio
vedere questa cosa che grazie ci si può
alzare bene spegne sacri studi tv non
alzare il volume spegne spegne bello
finché continua a scegliere tipo pene e
vagina
adesso è diventato un problema allora
ragazzi a un accendino
era un accendino posto accenderlo a casa
ok perfetto bella la fiamma e di che fa
una luce che l'amica una luce che fa
paura concreto questo gioco perché è
alquanto strano credo che bel quadro a
una sigaretta perfetto perché dovrei
ma com è non c'è l'accendino mi dispiace
ma sentite e ce la farò prima o poi
accendere una sigaretta
niente è difficile ragazzi comunque la
cosa che non ho dio che schifo vabbè ma
si sposta ma chi è merda scorta zio
vorresti affinare il tuo bene qua dentro
mai però posso infilarci la sigaretta
volendo no che schifo di merda tanto non
so come ho fatto ma mi sono un acceso
una sigaretta bene certo che nella mia
vita avrei pensato di tutto ma non di
trovarmi in un punto dove fisso un buco
nel muro dove escano scarafaggi e fumo
una sigaretta
sono cose che accadono ha messo dentro
ma perché ascolta zio esistono i
posaceneri che servono adesso tra i fumi
da lasciarla da dentro che meglio tanto
da far schifo ma i ragazzi
non ho capito ancora il senso di tutto
questo gioco però ok tanti ragazzi c'è
un altro quadro anche se ho paura di
vedere che cosa
ok è caduta una chiave perfetto una
chiave e va bene va bene per niente
uscire
non posso raccogliere più video così
insieme vero no perché io c'ho una mano
sola pavimento oltre all'occhio hanno
tagliato pallamano comunque ragazzi ho
trovato una chiave quindi apriamo la
porta di sicuro lo sapevo è veramente
come nel film c'è da io devo tagliare
l'occhio a qualcuno regala spiegatemelo
chiesto l'umore bruttissimo
ai jacob ciao jacob dunque parte di
cos'è è un porno è no cosa cosa ho preso
ho fumato una foglia di maria
continuando a fumare erba che cosa prima
di sigarette poi l'erba finiamo così
alla fine si questo ero io da piccolo
problema a parte formare la maria c'è
qualcosa qua delle uova
ma che cazzo sto giocando le piace una
mano
che bella ma che bella guarda c'è anche
il buco possiamo prenderlo al muro e
volevo dirti c'è anche una foto che
sembra un porno un porno non so se un
porno ma guarda grazie preferisco di no
continuo a vedere dei preservativi per
aria sono strafatto
c'è un taglierino che non userò perché
non interessa di tagliare le persone
comunque va bè entriamo a parte il fatto
che non c'è stavano che cosa dovrebbe se
l'attacco al muro ma vedi che sia da che
schifo ma perche ma dio mio ragazzi mi
fa veramente è la cosa più schifosa la
korea che merda ma cosa posso volendo
tipo bruciare tutti quanti se accendo la
sigaretta si ok adesso proviamo a vedere
se qualcosa serve perché non perfetto
sono arte cioè la bruciata sigaretta
uniti dovrebbero essere morte tutte no
non è morto un cazzo nessuno paga chi
cazzo lanciato questa roba
cioè cascata una scatola da dove non ho
capito lega pro c'è una io una chiave
cioè una chiave uso perché non ho capito
cosa ragazzi ecc ed abile e fondo
messico dentro questa cosa si può aprire
si sa bene a chi aveva per tutto è una
cosa pazzesca non si sa perché posso una
farfalla c'era una farfalla chiusi ho
capito ma il senso sconta zia vieni
vieni no vieni un attimo dove cazzo fai
niente bastarda senti zia mi fai un
favore ecco brava e guardate visione
perfetto no no no no nì queste scene non
guardare queste scene che sono brutte
non guardarle davis allora senti zia già
sono incazzato i preti supplico dove
cazzo andata dalla ferma ferma vieni qui
vieni no era sei stronzo quello madonna
di quella moda e non possono anche
picchiarla cioè dove vai torna qui
subito ecco bravi che obbedisce però a
rega posso sfumare
sia la luna ma che tristezza dopo la
tranquillità di questa persona mentre
succedono cose strane a casa è la cosa
più bello
si ok ragazzi cosa cazzo succede ma
quanta erba c'era in quella roba lì
vabbè ho preso posacenere o per sua
sigaretta intanto c'è la luna chi mi
guarda come è possibile
si continua a guardarla perdo arrivata
qua e qua a cosa scusatemi ragazze ma si
sa però si sa ma sì sì ho ucciso la luna
essere che questa è stata nelle mie più
grandi aspirazioni della vita fatti non
c'è più perfetto ragazzi se no da domani
non vedete più la luna colpa mia
non so come cazzo fate sparito il
tavolino sparita sica è sparito il buzz
è sparito tutto ma cosa c'è una porta
cos'è questo è diventato un porno
intanto cos'è sta roba è un porno
davvero ma come noi non sto guardando
niente ma ma giuro che non lo stavo
guardando sia acceso da solo si è acceso
da solo che succede allora sentite c'è
un letto c'è un quadro bel molto bello
dormire se io dormo da parte dove si
cade non ho capi questo devo fare ma che
chi sono i nuovi televisori c'è che
sembrano quadri ma che sono televisori
che si fanno vedere c'è per caso anche
youtube si vede la fine
ragazzi io non so che cosa dire sono la
persona più triste del mondo in questo
preciso momento perché non riesco a
spiegarmi a che cosa cazzo appena
giocato
mando gaza stato c'è lo hanno già ucciso
laguna regalo mi sono attrezzato pure
niente ragazzi hanno già uccisa quindi
quindi niente a questo punto ragazzi
concludo qui questo sembra un pazzo
maniaco però voi sapete perché sono
uscito se qualcuno mi sta vedendo così
chiama la polizia quindi ragazzi
servillo è piaciuto vasari tracciato
momento mi piace stanno svegliando tutto
il mondo me non frega un cazzo
anche la pagina di facebook come ogni
vidotto la tana descrizione se siete
dispiaciuti che è morta la luna perché
non decido lasciato un altro mi piace e
non si rivelavano passioni da da ragazzi
[Musica]